this video has been made possible by one
dream a platform dedicated to online
learning through thousands of courses
lectures and documentaries stick around
until the end to find out more
oh
[Music]
african myths and folklore are not
something we've really covered much on
this channel
there is no singular story or pantheon
that encompasses african mythology and
folklore as a whole so when choosing
where to start i've chosen one of the
few figures i had heard of a figure
prominent in west africa but one whose
stories and identity have evolved and
traveled across africa to the caribbean
and north america a figure that
possessed ideals many wish to emulate
but also one with flaws that served as
cautionary tales and lessons
today we examine the legend of anansi
the spider
anansi is a character that appears in a
khan folklore which primarily covers the
countries of ghana and the ivory coast
with the language being spoken by 80
percent of those who live in ghana many
consider this to be the origin of a
nancy and his stories anansi derives
from the word meaning spider and he does
appear as an animal as well as several
other forms sometimes he is a man other
times a spider and he can also be both a
spider with a man's head or a man with
spider-like qualities such as eight legs
or arms
his primary role is as a trickster his
stories often involve him being cunning
and outsmarting his adversaries
one of the biggest debates i came across
was whether the stories of a nancy
should be classified as folklore or
mythology the reason i bring this up is
because it's an interesting discussion
that applies to all types of myths and
folklore from everywhere anansi is the
son of nyami the sky god which would
also make an unsee a god and therefore
its mythology discussion over
well
not exactly anansi is not really
referred to as the tricks to god he
serves as the intermediary between his
father and the rest of the world
he also displays mortal qualities as
well as being somewhat of a cult hero
and thus why many consider these to be
folk tales over mythology
many of nancy's tales were told through
oral storytelling they were not recorded
until much later
similar to how the vodun religion spread
from west africa and became haitian
voodoo anansi and the akhan folklore
were transmitted and travelled through
the caribbean and north america via the
trans-atlantic slave trade
those who were taken from their homes
and transported to this new world would
only really have their memories and
stories their traditions and so anansi's
importance was even greater than before
many of these spider tales see a nancy
overcoming impossible odds outwitting
individuals who were much more powerful
than himself it's not difficult to see
why nancy was a symbol of hope and
rebellion during this period they would
have to display quality similar to
anansi if they wish to overcome their
oppressors
one story used to highlight this is the
story of the lion and the tiger
in this story the lion considered
himself the mightiest and so the tiger
should bow down to him and unsee who was
below the tiger would have to bow down
to both of them
the tiger accepted his position however
anansi did not
he whispered in the lion's ear to be
careful
the tiger thinks he is the rightful
ruler when the lion next saw the tiger
he killed him and thanked nancy for his
servitude you are the rightful ruler
mighty lion and unsee accepted
presenting the lion with some water
whilst preoccupied with the tiger the
lion had not seen anansi poison his
drinking water and so he also died and
nancy was now free
you can see how stories similar to this
may have resonated with those who are
enslaved this was also a very common
theme in these spider stories
there is usually someone bigger or
stronger who underestimates a nancy but
they do so at their own peril as the
spider outsmarts them
one of the most well-known stories is
how all of the sky god stories became a
nancy's
there was a time when no stories existed
except the ones owned by the sky god
anansi wanted these stories and the
wisdom that came with them and so he
visited the sky god and offered to buy
them
nyame scoffed
and how would you afford such a price
the biggest and richest kingdoms have
tried to purchase my stories and yet
none could afford them
i promise i can
name your price
anansi replied nyame contemplated how
the spider could possibly keep his
promise
he gave him a set of labors tasks that
he deemed impossible
then fetch me the most dangerous animals
onini the python osabo the leopard
the umboro hornet and the fairy malaysia
anansi accepted the challenge but before
he set off nyami added anansi's mother
to the list
anansi returned to his home and devised
a plan of action with his wife aso and
his mother to capture the python he
gathered some vines and the branch of a
palm tree and met his wife at the river
where onini would be
together they began to stage an argument
as to the length of the python
a nancy claiming onini's body was larger
than the branch of a full grown palm
tree
overhearing the two o'nini was curious
anansi explained his wife did not
believe onini was bigger than the branch
and so the python agreed to end this
discussion as it stretched its body
against the branch anansi took the vines
and tied onini to the branch the trap
they had set was a success and the
python was taken to the sky god
anansi returned to his wife and together
they came up with a plan to capture the
hornets
he found a calabash and filled it with
water this is essentially the hardened
shell of a fruit that can be used to
store food or as a bottle when a nancy
had found the hornets he began to pour
water over them making sure to pour
water over himself he then took a banana
leaf and used it to cover his head when
the irate's hornets flew over to him he
was also drenched
taking a look at the banana leaf he was
using as a makeshift umbrella the
hornets believed the nancy when he said
it was raining
the rain is dangerous and it may also
get worse
here use my calabash as shelter the
hornets thanked hanunzi and flew inside
his container once they had all entered
he sealed the top of the calabash
trapping the hornets inside
he then took them to the sky god
as you may have gathered by now he
returned to his wife and together they
devised a plan to catch osabo the
leopard to do this anansi dug a hole and
covered it with branches the leopard
came running by and fell into this pit
in one interpretation anansi helps
oseibo out of the hole using his web but
he refuses to cut him loose and drags
him to the sky god
in another story anansi gave the leopard
two large sticks to hold onto whilst he
pulled him out of the hole the leopard
with both arms outstretched grabbed the
sticks however he was now in a
compromising position anansi reached
over for his knife and dropped it into
the hole the hilt of the knife hitting
the defenseless leopard on the head and
knocking him unconscious anansi dragged
the sleeping leopard out of the hole and
took him to the sky god
in order to catch the fairy anansi
carved a doll and covered it with sap
from a tree making it sticky he then
took a yam mashed it and placed it under
a tree where the fairies would pass
when the fairy saw the bowl of yam she
asked the doll if she could have some
using his web as strings anansi pulled
on them and the doll nodded the fairy
ate the yam and thanked the doll however
anansi did not respond the fairy took
offence to the doll not acknowledging
her gratitude
and so she gave the doll a slap but her
hand had become stuck in the gummy
substance
she then used her other hand to slap the
doll again
now both hands were stuck
anansi finally showed himself tying up
the helpless fairy and taking her home
before returning to the sky god one last
time he explained the deal he had made
to his mother and she agreed to come
with him
presenting the sky god with the fairy
and his mother anansi had honored his
promise
nyami summoned the elders and explained
that the spider before them had
succeeded where the great and mighty
kingdoms had failed
with his blessing the sky got announced
that all stories that exist shall now be
known as spider stories
the story of how wisdom was spread
around the world is quite interesting
mostly because it's not about anansi
overcoming impossible odds and showing
his intellect it's a story where anansi
shows his more human side
on a rather stormy day anansi decided to
gather all of the wisdom in the world
and keep it for himself
he did so by placing all of the wisdom
in a large pot he then found the largest
tree believing the very top to be a
great place to hide all of this wisdom
he tied the pot in front of him and
tried climbing the tree
anansi's youngest son had seen his
father and decided to follow him what he
then observed was anger and frustration
as whenever his father made some slight
progress he came sliding back down the
tree the weight of the pot was too much
to hoist above him and climb at the same
time
his son laughed and called out to his
father
why don't you try tying the pot behind
you that way you'll be free to climb
uninhibited
anansi still frustrated looked down at
his son and decided to continue doing
things his way
however during this moment the pot
slipped and came crashing down
the storm dispersed the wisdom through
the forest carried by the air and the
river the wisdom had soon spread
throughout the entire kingdom and
further although anansi had failed he
soon realized that his son was correct
what point is there in having all of the
wisdom in the world if a child can solve
the solution to your problem before you
can
this is one of nancy's stories where he
displays these undesirable traits such
as greed and stubbornness but in the end
he sees the error of his ways and comes
to the realization that maybe wisdom
being spread equally is better than
being hoarded by one person
the last story we'll be covering today
is the story of the night the moon and
the sun
it also involves anansi becoming the sky
god's messenger
in this story nyame had three children
the knight the moon and the sun when
they came of age they left their father
and built their own villages nyame
intended for one of them to become chief
and so he decided to have a competition
with the winner taking his throne as
proof of their new status
out of the three children yami had
always favored the youngest who
represented the sun itself when he
announced his plan he harvested a yam
and gave it a name the child who was
able to guess the name would be the
winner anansi hearing this told nyami
that he already knew the name however
this was a lie the sky god paid no
notice to anansi's claims and asked him
to gather his three sons for him an
unseen now rather curious decided he
would return to find out what exactly
the sky god was plotting gathering the
feathers of every bird he could find
anansi covered himself and flew back to
the village disguised as a bird
when the sky god saw nancy he laughed
and said i've never seen such a peculiar
looking bird before if the spider was
here he would know what type of bird you
are
nonetheless a nancy's disguise had
worked and he was able to hear
everything the sky god had planned even
the name of the yam
with this newfound information he flew
away to fetch the sky god's children
he first arrived at the village of the
eldest son the son known as the knight
he told him his father wished to see him
and to show his hospitality he gave a
nancy some roasted corn before leaving
anansi then arrived at the village of
the second son the son known as the moon
anansi delivered the same news and was
given a yam as a sign of hospitality
and nancy then arrived at the village of
the youngest son
the son known as
well the son
the youngest of the three sons told
anansi that as his father's chosen
messenger he must sit down and enjoy the
same level of hospitality he would
afford his father he prepared an unsee
the best lamb they had and together they
had a feast anansi could see why the sky
god favored the youngest of his children
in return for his hospitality anansi
told him of his father's plans and gave
him the name of the yam anansi created a
pair of drums that would shout to the
name of the yam in order to help him
remember when all three children had
arrived at the sky gods village the
first up was the eldest son
when asked to guess the name of the yam
he was wrong as punishment for the sun
known as the night the sky god declared
that from now on evil things will be
done during the night
the second son stepped forward and just
like the first his guess was also wrong
as punishment for the sun known as the
moon the sky god declared that from now
on the moonlight shall be where mischief
shall occur
and so lastly the youngest son stepped
forward but before he could guess anansi
began to beat his drum reminding him of
the yam's name
his guess was correct
the village rejoiced and the sky god had
gotten the chief he wanted with some
assistance from a nancy of course the
sky god declared that the sunlight would
be where issues and disputes are settled
he also gave his younger son a rainbow
to protect himself from harm
having a feeling that an unseen may have
played a part in all of this he also
announced that from that day anansi
would be known as his messenger
anansi is certainly an interesting
character
there are stories where he interacts
with gods and individuals much more
powerful than himself sometimes they
bestow supernatural powers upon him
being able to control the elements for
example which is why he is at times
categorized as a deity other times we
see him shapeshift and behave more like
a trickster spirit which is why he may
also be seen as a lesser deity
there are dozens of stories detailing
anansi's adventures and shenanigans we
may return and cover more of these
spider stories if there is enough
interest
until then let me know your thoughts on
a nancy
as we mentioned earlier today's video
has been sponsored by the awesome people
over at one dream
one dream aims to answer the questions
you never even knew needed the asking
they've combined forces of the great
courses plus to expand their catalogue
and provide an even more immersive
experience
you can stream unlimited videos
documentaries
series and courses on a wide range of
topics you can also do this on multiple
devices in your own time at whatever
pace suits you
if you enjoyed today's dive into african
folklore then i'd recommend great
mythologies of the world or myth in
human history as both courses have
several episodes devoted to african
legends as well as many other cultures
from around the world if you'd like to
try one dream for yourself then visit
onedrive.com mythology to start your
free trial today so why not give it a
try as it really helps support the
channel
as always
i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
you